hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I am in San
Diego right now Comic Cons going on I
had the fortunate opportunity to
introduce a film and host the Q&A Comic
Con so right now I'm in San Diego this
is a friend's place I'm at but there's a
video that dropped that I was like I
gotta check this out Star Wars The Force
awakens Comic Con 2015 the real are EE L
like the real rejects see the real it's
so clever it's not reall r-e yeah you
know god I look so [ __ ] beautiful
already
real sets practical effect practical
effects been here but you don't know
this story nothing's changed really I
mean everything's changed but nothing's
changed that's the way you want it to be
really ha ha ha ha ha the technology has
evolved and yet keeping one foot in the
pre-digital world so cool it's so more
exciting it's still surreal we are here
on day one of star wars episode 7 yeah
I can die now whole night has led to
this moment
I think we've worn the suit out probably
quicker than we expected people set
every time you meet someone they just
want to hug it get back to the old days
the old ways of doing things
yeah JJ is trying to make sure these
movies have a physicality to them we
truly are out in a desert a real desert
Star Wars I burned this tower you don't
get to build an x-wing every day or a
Millennium Falcon every day I come to
work smiling oh my god it looks so good
she's got the pose take a breath slow
down and really freak out
wires oh my god in the same room is all
these legends and with all these new
people who are sharable and the legend
success you know it's being done with
such love and such enthusiasm from
everybody and I think that you'll be
able to feel like coming off the screen
it means so much as so many people
you just know what's gonna be like in
the cinema star was just an important
part of everyone's history it's a
beautiful thing to actually be involved
in it
that is my most anticipated movie of
2015
hands down it looks like it's just gonna
be beautifully captured you know like
it's one of those things I was like you
know even if you end this movie and you
don't really like it because of story or
whatever I'm telling you there's clearly
plenty here to appreciate especially the
practical effects we're in a day and age
where CGI is so overused and whenever
there's practical people [ __ ] love it
so to do with Star Wars such memorable
practical effects that's [ __ ]
rewarding man I'm excited anyway thanks
for saying that was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine and
I just got a periscope to Luke Edwards
hey Ryan I love your channel I've been
trying to get a shout out for ages like
some freaky fangirl um lord knows I got
too many of those but seriously it would
make me life make my life if you could
give my YouTube channel it's called luke
central a shout out where i talk about
movies unique do reactions double the
uniqueness and rants triple the
uniqueness and skits this sounds a lot
like my channel another random [ __ ]
sounds a lot like my channel but and my
channel is clearly a lot like other
people's channels would have way more
followers than me PS you and Jerry
should do a comedy skit thing because
you make a good pair he actually just
texted me today with a short film idea
so Luke you're probably gonna get what
you want
Luke Central is a great channel his
reactions are they're so funny they're
authentic they're sincere it really just
come from the heart when I started doing
reactions I did it before everyone else
realized that they all too can do what I
do because it's really not hard
but thank you for viewing this video